everybody and welcome to another
matplotlib video and we'll matplotlib
miniseries for Python 3 and last video I
showed you guys how we can use styles
and in this video I want to show you
guys a few more customization that
Styles isn't necessarily going to help
you very much with and that's with
adding in legends so when you plot
there's all kinds of values that you can
stick in here XY color can always be in
this order so if you remember back to
our series about what order do you put
values in when you call functions now
the matplotlib is highly customizable so
there's a lot of stuff that we can do
with matplotlib just so there's a of the
functions like plot the plot function
there are just so many things that you
can do with it in so many parameters
that you can pass through XY in color
are the first ones but then there's a
whole bunch of other ones so that's why
we've specified line width equals what
and then now we're going to specify even
further a label so with that let's go
ahead and get started and say so line
width equals 5 and then we're going to
say label y equals a line 1 and then
we'll come down here and we'll say label
equals line 2 so now we've got some
labels but we can see here if we save
and run that nothing actually changes
you know in our chart we don't really
see anything so now let's go ahead and
do one more thing and let's add a legend
so underneath all the labels you can
pretty much put this anything after
you've made all your plots but we just
basically want to do PLT legend and what
legend is going to do is just it's just
gonna call the legend to show up so now
we've got the legend we can see that not
only does the color and the table come
through but even you can see the line
thickness has come through so anyway
that's how you can get a legend there
are ways to move the legend around you
can specify the location of the legend
and all of that now
um for now we'll just leave it up there
finally the other thing I want to show
you guys is gridlines so as you can see
this chart naturally has a grid line to
it because we're using styles we can
come up here comment out style and we
see that actually by default there is no
grid being shown to us so we can close
out of this and we can come out here to
plot legend and we can call grid so we
can say PLT grid and then first
parameter is whether or not it's true or
false we want to say it's true and then
next thing that we'll say is we want to
specify the color now you can have all
kinds of colors for the grid for example
we can use G for green it actually
doesn't look too bad because it's dotted
but oh you can come back over here and
most people are going to use probably K
which is black and we'll save and run
that again and then so now you see we
have the grids it could be useful to
note though the following so as you can
see here the grid is going over it now
if you remember everything comes in the
order that you call it so we've drawn
the grid really last so the question is
can we move the grid above the plots
because grid isn't like the legend it
doesn't require any prior data so what
if we did that and we save and run it
and we plot it and we see that no the
grid always is going to go over the data
ok so anyway I just wanted to show that
because if you plot C like line 2 is
above line 1 because line 2 was drawn
second and then really the legend is
above all else because the legend was
trying last oops anyway just wanted to
cover those things so that's going to
conclude this tutorial on those things
that I wanted to cover here still got a
couple more things that I want to show
you guys with mat plot lips so stay
tuned for that if you guys have any
questions or comments on this video
please feel free to leave them below as
always thanks for watching things for
all the support and subscriptions
anything last time